why is it that the bid Administration
has been trafficking illegal immigrants
to all of these different cities what
did we see with Co we saw the more
conservative-minded individuals fleeing
to Texas and Florida Florida turns deep
red everybody comes out and says oh
Ronda sandis you're the greatest
Governor I did a good job but let's
let's also consider the fact that with
all of these people moving into Miami
moving into Florida for Refuge that has
Stripped Away a large portion of the
more right-leaning voters and base in
these places which will now be replaced
by illegal immigrants who are being
trafficked into Chicago into New York
into these liberal places the first
thing that it will do is in the in in
the in this census in the next census it
will give an imbalance of power to
Democrats it is estimated that
California has between one and maybe
even as high as seven extra
congressional seats and electoral votes
based on illegal immigrant population